de très violents affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre serait
responsable du décès d'un jeune homme de
22 ans on sait qui a tué votre frère et
il va falloir en prendre toute la mesure
de sa sortie
les peluches ou
et n'offre une version solide
ils essaient de forcer le non-lieu en
accusant malik de ce qui lui est arrivé
c'est toujours la même méthode ans
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
rien ne permet d'affirmer qu'il s'agit
de bezonnes ça peut être n'importe qui
on a plusieurs témoins et montrent
pourquoi il tirait il
tirait tous
chose ne va pas déborder dans notre camp
serwa notera qu'en dessous de la justice
vous savez ce que je pense de cette
justice là
[Musique]
c'est très cher de continuer à protéger
l'institution
bercy
et au dessus des lois
on cherche pas être aimés nous
ce qu'on veut c'est traiter à égalité
c'est tout
[Musique]